hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pony island this got
off to a really dramatic start and I'm
hoping to keep this going for a long
time we start out on the Oh I do that
okay oh ah hopeless soul hopeless soul
that was the guy wait a minute wait
hopeless soul was the guy that I was
talking to and then oh that says Lucifer
oh I get it with the symbol that is [ __ ]
and balls and then I'm guest so whoever
was that other person that I didn't talk
to is deleted there's four there were
four people here or at least that's what
I'm picking up from this screen right
here there were four and I just killed
one of them through whatever actions I
have password I didn't mean to do that
triangle ah that's a that's a lot of
wait a minute zoom in on that triangle
noth-nothing go I how are you
alright so walk through for a bit then
boots up get prep today but good click
guests hit the submit no password need
to click on messenger to speak with me
again oh hello
please respond when you find this
message you are deciever good it's good
to see oh good old Marquis mu so crazy
and his accusations false prophet he
said what hello I saw that I was looking
away talking to myself no you did well
with that first core file however we
still have with the other two despite
the amount of data that was corrupted
security will be increased it won't be
easy for me to open another portal I
have an idea login to my user profile
the password is 2 7 3 4 thanks man it's
not like Lucifer can't see this it's a 2
7 3 4 so I already don't trust this guy
I'm usually the first to be like that
fall bullshitting I don't like it so 2 7
3 4 ah you made it over yes I'm here but
where are you
he's never guessed my password thus far
never did little do you better anyway so
alright what do we have search programs
what about portal generation can I do
that can I do it oh I can't do it moved
messenger search frogs wait a minute
what's BA oh I thought that was gonna be
something behind there I thought I was
gonna be sneaky right fine
what is this yes that's the one hoody
garble okay ah that's a lot less garbled
okay security least to greatest oh ah
Pony Island you see what this means no
not at all I don't know if you want to
be free from this machine you must delve
into Pony Island once more I don't envy
you
but it must be done why why must it be
done Pony Island and play it as soon as
I am able I will open a portal Dori the
crumpet profile next to mine may be
worth investigating
eyes out the one I killed cuz I don't
trust you I don't trust you I don't
trust you at all alrighty then
oh I'll do what you say I don't I don't
know what the oh yeah yeah that's right
we don't need a password that was my
leet hacking skills getting in the way
of everything
hello eyeball let me poke you in the
cross um
burp did who did password backup guest
none hopeless Sultan 734 corrupted IM
Aurore ponies Oh
ponies okay you got it ponies it is
hello hi are you still watching me why
are you watching me also I still
remember that like the whole the whole
arcade cabinet slanted I didn't even
know that ooh
welcome back oh that's so
ah Seth look settlers of sit on I like
that
can i play this and I've relived played
it much my Road Oh Rick okay roll right
roll rick roll hey I got it
alright I got it I got a ticket a Batman
okay messenger say yes master we will
see welcome back okay so he's already
said welcome back to me he knows I'm
here he's okay he's all he's all jazzed
up okay here we go
yeah maybe I could you know stand like I
I know I have horrible posture but maybe
I could just straighten my spine just
our hair in the right direction so that
I'd be able to do I need to do ah good
old Satan tech made some of the best
classics of the 90s like who Satan
Island doom yes
anyway boney Island now fully
you have been busy
so have I I have made some changes
Island
adventure mode is a game design
revolution please refrain from cheating
this time okay I don't know about that
cheating is just in my blood you've
gotta be just a minor bug
Fix no I'm gonna go in what is that it's
a portal it's a portal nice okay it's a
portal
I know how portals work I've been
thinking with portals since I was 12
years old here we go
I fixed it for you no need for you to
fix
I do fix oh this is new there is a huge
amount of corrupted data north of you
our best chance at opening another
portal lies there just play along and no
or what is that oh okay we'll go go on
okay ah same idea huh but I don't have I
don't have my lasers oh there we go
okay so I need wait laser power ah loop
around here okay so I know what needs to
happen we're gonna loop loop loop loop
we're gonna build up the power of this
gosh damn laser hey I got a lot of
goddamn time I don't have to wait for
nobody I can be here until the end of my
days so I'm gonna get laser power 69 and
you're goddamn right I'm patient enough
to wait for that to happen so here we go
[Music]
you can't see it but I'm rusting my hips
in an O so sensual manner Oh nail jaw
and boink
ah I'm a genius hey I got level 69 [ __ ]
69 level laser you have no idea how
powerful the son of a [ __ ] is like it's
it's gone to the year 69 69
it has battled all of the dick elders
from that time period and then stole
every single one of their lasers and
destroyed them died just no no no what
are you aah
no you don't we don't know you do there
you go
you didn't know what was coming at ya
just in case you didn't know who's a
laser a level 69 waser
did it nailed it I'm owing to the great
gap it is really quiet here
Oh fire my laser ah okay well this seems
to be a problem I don't think I can beat
this with lasers which is quite a
conundrum
I'm almost entirely used to exclusively
lasering my way through all my problems
that level is a little tricky
try levelling up first you can grind for
exp over here um thank you for the
advice you're awfully kind I mean it
just seems to me like whoever this guy
is talking to me he just wants me to
have a good time with his game like
that's literally all he wants he made a
game he wants people to play it for a
long time
he's worked very hard at it and for some
reason this other guy wants to dismantle
it all now why would that be I mean me
I'm just a guy at an arcade cap I could
leave at any time I'm just enjoying me
myself here which would also lead me to
believe like I would have no reason to
not participate because me as suits of
players looking at this be like hey this
is a really interesting game but also me
as a person is also a player out here
going hey this is a really interesting
game wonder why it is yeah I gained
Oh
Oh you've got an incredibly skewed sense
of time well time to loopy loop yeah
I've got enough patience for this thing
to go all over the place okay so how
motion oh okay okay yeah
doink doink doink doink nope that ain't
doing it it's got to be over here that's
the one okay then this out boink boink
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah did
it did it did it did it why can't you
play my game the way I intended enjoy
the wings thank you cheater
see this guy seems nice he just wants me
to play the game that he has spent so
much time making he spent he's really
legitimately trying to make a perfect up
game here I can't really fault him for
that oh that's cool
I like that demonic and awesome I love
that hey Lord can tweet the laser dragon
pony
I'm having a great time I'm having a
wonderful time
ticket lake I want to go to ticket Lake
how can I get a ticket a ticket Lake I
just have to fire my laser
whenever I go up into the sky anybody
want to taste them a laser anybody no
literally no one wants to taste my laser
it's made fresh within the depth Wow
okay thank you that's nice of you
does anybody remember the laser
compilation dr. octagon a puss and all
that stuff
the height of the laser meme got full I
died was talking about memes and of
course I failed
goddamnit alright fast forwarding back
to where I wasn't such an idiot I mean
admittedly the guy's name is Lucifer and
he seems to run say tantek so you know
you gotta give things worth you know
like it's a little it's a little iffy
and I don't want to ona point fingers or
anything but if I had to go huh I wonder
who's probably not a good guy he's
probably gonna be this guy cliff of
trials I don't want to go there I want
to get the ticket the weeping hollow
who that sounds bad I can't even go
there I can go there whoa why am I in
the weeping hollow why would I want to
go here oh hi do I want you I'm gonna
get you all right
I thought it was gonna kill me I did it
okay Lillian Butte is corn gone okay
okay then please carry on I got a ticket
or I got a coin
can I get good good ticket please
oh okay all right let's go
I suppose Oh back to normal are we with
cliffs in the background oh boy is that
like there's like another
like another wing that popped out
sometimes
oh okay cut it close there bubble hit it
and you're dead and you're dead and what
happened something happened well I did
it I got it made the game's not too bad
I just I kind of want to know how to get
that ticket and I have a funny feeling
that maybe I should go through this
again can't go through the one on the
Left far backward I'll go faster shoots
out my boy
hmm there's something going on there but
I can't seem to figure it out so I'm
gonna keep moving forward
hello ah I see something up there
Oh what is this I don't know this is for
with this pool okay it's far under zero
okay okay so this should be good right
all I need to do is portal it over here
now okay and we got it it's negative
seven it's far more than needed hey it
unlocked the square but maybe it
unlocked another's
oh ah I see you I saw you I found you
secret
oh hello hi hi hi ho hi ho uh-huh okay
now we got something here
now we definitely got something ooh I'm
on the river styx I don't know why I'm
here but I'm here to buy a world
goodbye pony world I'm gonna go
[Music]
you
I'm not a I'm not a pony anymore
I'm not a pony anymore I'm a little
confused as to what kind of
transformation happened out there on the
water did I go through some weird
temporal rift that somehow turned me
into a bipedal Pony I've no idea little
bizarre and I seem to be a crusader as
well and I I don't know what to think
about that okay I'm just gonna carry on
if I still got wings and can shoot
lasers I guess I'm okay but oh I wasn't
even paying attention I was looking at
the skull cloud there's still a lot of
unknown elements in this game that I'm
trying to decide like obviously it's
trying to be meta in some way but
there's some backstory here or not I
like it I always use when I'm playing
these games I always try to figure out
like what exactly is a story what's the
motivation why with the speed why would
this guy because it's an important story
element it's not just an anecdotal thing
that I'm a real person sitting at an
arcade cabinet and there's something
really going on with this like they're
legitimately is something really going
on so it has to mean that there's like
substance behind it there's there's
legitimacy to who this person is who
made this cabinet and also why this
particular guy's playing it and also why
he's not walking away like these are all
things that I think come into play
because I'd like to assume that it's not
just unsubstantiated just [ __ ] ari
Hait will get you with Bellator's you're
a new guy too
do you know what's going on here
can't hit me are you dead yet are you
not dead yet ah there you go you're dead
so also like the discrepancy between the
lost soul and the lucifer character like
who they are in this in this endeavor
because if the lost soul is actually
lost and not just sitting at an arcade
cabinet hoping to get tickets then
there's something more to it you know
what I mean or maybe I'm looking into
this far too much which is an entire
possibility and I get lost in the lore
sometimes and I don't want to there may
not be anything in this game but Stan's
not gonna stop me from making the
connections anyway so hello hello graces
it's a lot of levels okay I got it
Joe but there was the cave of truths
okay but before that I'm gonna check
over here to the layoffs cuz there was
something over y'all I don't know this
is
but keeps a brooch coming out of the
cave of truth first because if I'm going
towards some sort of key that probably
means something that the loosey Ferg a
has so let's go find out some truth here
you've done well to find me mortal and
are back to leave this place or I may
show you a vision how about a vision a
glimpse ah oh now you may ask one of
three questions who was I when did I die
who killed me okay okay
now we know something very interesting
I'm dead that's fascinating
I'm literally dead I am 100% dead so who
killed me is an interesting question
only if that pertains to someone else in
this game when did I die is an
interesting thing because it would tell
me how long I've been in the game the
only thing that doesn't matter in any
capacity in this one is who was I
because it's irrelevant who you were
because that's dad that doesn't matter
in the consequence of where you are
right now so either who killed me or
when did I die I guess it would be kind
of interesting to know how long I've
been in this place but I'd rather know
who killed me because that implies
someone killed me his name was Abu al
Kindi he fought for his city uh I was a
soldier now that's fascinating thank you
I said thank you what oh that's so
interesting I can't go back in there and
ask another thing No Oh No okay goodbye
oh that's so interesting
oh so I wait a minute
my character right now is literally a
crusader
[Music]
yeah that couldn't that couldn't be it
why what would a crusader even do in
this weird bizarre techno world like oh
that's that's really fascinating oh I
got that opens up a lot of doors I know
I know this games been out for like
happier already so I know that people
have already poured through this as it
is but I am so curious right now oh
that's so fascinating oh that tickles
everything what is it like how does it
all relate how does it all relate why
civically me am I here or could that
just be my character in this game and
not necessarily
you're doing so great now I need time to
create more content for you why don't
you take a break
I insist no I'm having fun
Oh position button
I don't know how to persistently harm I
guess I will do a little bit of this
section here [ __ ]
okay so now I need the Y position up one
okay so now it's gonna loop through so
and now x position needs to be below
yeah it's gonna be complicated okay okay
now it's good okay now it's good now
it's good now it's good now okay
no I'm good thank you
oh content all done oh content all done
now
oh content I'll go on oh no for you
content all Gani bye
I failed you take a break I need more
time
you're not ready for the
boss fight I think I am let me just go
up some more levels just a typo hold on
ah I see oh hey ah more content dot
build I hope it's good it's got to work
down okay
that shows that the creator of this game
is doubting himself
and that's more interesting what was
that function ponies are cute hope hope
oh that's so interesting too dark right
now more friendly content needs to be
friendlier what is a friend oh that's so
interesting
oh that's so interesting
oh that's so interesting oh it's so
fascinating okay I'm gonna blast through
this and boink boink okay got it now we
got enough data we got a whole smack
around the data we got to get for the
Studer more time panicking you need more
time oh man oh hi mascot hainan oh
you're so cute so cute
slow down I don't think so maybe you
need to speed up not loading oh [ __ ]
so when I first got to do is I got to
get a data all the way up to 100 it's
gonna happen read about right there then
I can get a date over here and then I
can just loop through the pattern of
this [ __ ] here now we're gonna get B
data up to a hundred point point point
okay then we need C data okay no that's
not what I meant
shits gonna be y'all it's not gonna be
even oh god it's not gonna be even oh
well whatever it's not pretty but it is
what it is done it's not ready don't
look I want to look at all I really do
show me come on please oh it's upside
down that's a problem as a problem poor
game design IGN three out of ten Jesus
Christ needs more Doritos I'm asking you
doing
oh boy hey ticket lake tickets no more
oh boy if I recall maybe I can go back
to the cable oh hello skull through the
desert there was a cave of truth but uh
maybe I could ask another question hello
no okay that's not the case but I guess
I can go to the boss fight now maybe
that's gonna mean something for me I
definitely know that I've been missing
out on some tickets here and there but I
think I can forgive myself cuz I'm not
exactly completionist I'm good
oh okay boss fight it is as not ready as
it may be you made it the final level
Adventure Holden I wanted to have more
of a build up but you're here so we
might as well do this the final boss is
me of course if you lose your soul is
mine my leave ace oh that's that's some
friendly content right there well I
can't seem to hit you huh who's cheating
now I've done it
take this portal to the war file okay
goodbye
yeah come on dude oh it's beauty boob
oh hi poz boob are you doing oh hey whoa
okay never mind
whoa that was expected how is that
expected old [ __ ] I don't uh okay really
I wasn't doing it right let's break
these symbols and break these rocks
oh I jumped right into that fist okay so
I need to not do the jumping
oh [ __ ] yeah okay thank you for being
nice okay so I got you all right so now
I'm getting this boss fight a little
better
Oh God part of its heads gone oh well
just like playing Bastion and overwatch
so easy
it's got click and hold then keep your
eye on the target oh no your chin pull
your poor little baby chin oh thank you
fire your Ned oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh I am
the vinner ah delete core file well
played
you're a true warrior now click this
shortcut let's take down this core Oh No
you're being led astray can't you see
that destroying of these files will
prevent you from playing only Island Oh
but destroying the file is the only way
to advance oh damn
hi okay this is my chance I'm doing it
thanks for the distraction
Oh security breach oh jeez Steve oh god
that's in real that's in real maybe not
real life considering I'm dead if that
is true cuz I was programmed in the game
as well who knows if that's right or
wrong oh jeez Oh what is this
oh hi I am in an arcade I am oh my god
that's amazing I love that is Cobb wits
on it down though how long was I out for
okay so that's all the time I got for
this episode it ran longer than I
thought it would but this is just so
interesting so I'm gonna play this again
I don't know how much longer there is in
the game but there's one more core file
to delete so I consume that's as much as
we're gonna be able to do so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
bounce to mu1 yeah in in it let it go
did it go ah
[Music]